hello guys and welcome back to opengl
the next episode and here is where we
are
we're basically going to be setting some
uniforms
and show how to do some debugging with
that and fix a few corrections from last
video
where i'm very surprised that no one
actually called out
well when i was calling the function i
was passing the va out what it actually
needs
is the shader so i passed it the shader
identity and it works
fine so here's the console as we can see
we got color and position as
active inputs uh and i've also went
ahead and set up the uniform code
so it's now up there on the repo
[Music]
and we also did a few other things which
i'll go over real quick
basically the short version is we are
now ready to do
whatever we want with shaders and i'm
going to go ahead and walk through all
these
changes to have all that ready for next
video when we'll start
actually doing all some shader magic and
we're going to learn a lot here guys
believe me trust me subscribe let's do
this
i did some auto formatting with my ide
so a bunch of stuff looks like it got
changed because you know it's all green
here in github but it didn't actually
get changed
uh but i did change query at trips to
query shader and it now has the uniform
one in there as well which is down here
at the bottom query uniforms
so that way we can pass in a shader
handle and
check what uniforms are available and we
can
arbitrarily do this for any of our
shaders so it's just something to be
aware of
it's like the main thing of this
tutorial this is doing that
making some corrections final prep here
and i also added in
a little bit of basic model math
where you can see i pushed to this
uniform called you model matrix
so i went ahead and created the shader
files as glsl
files and i open them with visual studio
just regular visual studio because it
seems to have better syntax handling
so there's the vert shader there's the
fragment shader pretty straightforward
uh the model matrix is there as a map
for uniform and we just times it by the
position to get the final position
i could get rid of this whole final
position here and just put the math
right at the end here
but i like having it like this because
it gives us some play room here
to do stuff before we assign the final
position
so that's the point of declaring
variables within local blocks
is uh you can do some processing let's
walk through some more code here
i added a little time function just
started out the previous time
get the current time every loop get the
delta time the difference between it and
then set the previous to the current so
it'll be ready to update for next frame
that way we can do stuff with delta time
on the spitting
spinning triangle you saw a little bit
we start our
final model matrix as just a identity
matrix
first we translate it and the way i'm
making it go in
a donut like circle there is with the
sine and cosine
thing let's get out of select mode here
there we go now the sine of whatever the
current time is and the cosine of it on
the x and y
and divided by two so it was going off
the screen otherwise
and of course the z is just zero since
we're not doing anything with projection
or
view yet and then i rotate it
scale it i'm just rotating with the time
as well
and doing a scale to half the size
and then we get the location of that
viewmodel matrix variable
and set it to what it is updated to be
so we do this every loop
and then we draw all of the things
in our draw details from uploading which
we did on episode
whichever one or two and that's pretty
much it swap buffers
pull events still got some old code in
here from the random number generator
which is right here we might use that
later
what else did i change i'll just go
through it all
callbacks are the same i just removed
static
source i believe we went through most of
this i did have to include
the matrix transform to do those
operations with
glm otherwise i think we already went
through all that file
utilities i added the read to string
one of them that just returns a string
this is the one we're using
there's also one here where you can pass
it a string that fills out
essentially the same function just two
ways of re handling that string
let's check out the mesh loader it's all
the same i just removed static
some of those functions i believe they
should just be inline here's the
query i was renamed to query shader
there's that new function that we added
the query uniforms
this was basically just taken off that
same site we looked at
opengl cookbook but the code is pretty
generic if you just look up the
functions you'll see that you can
basically do
anything you want with them so yeah
that's pretty much it
from now on we're mostly going to be
but we're going to render a core object
like a square or triangle or a circle
and then we're going to do some
operations on it with these shaders
and we're going to start getting into
some of that kind of how to do effects
or different things
and just basically start opening up the
realm of shader possibility here that is
the really the main goal of this series
so i hope you follow and i'll see you
guys next time
peace out
[Music]
foreign